[Aplausos]
[Música]
en poco más de diez días la repubblica
de afganistán se vino abajo y los
talibanes hicieron con el poder en todo
el país solo una provincia de la
provincia de panshir hoy foco de una
incipiente resistencia logró evitar la
avalancha el avance talibán fue tan
rápido que tal y como todos pudisteis
ver en vivo y en directo llegaron a
poner contra la espada y la pared a las
mismísimas fuerzas norteamericanas que
tenían la misión de comandar la
evacuación el caos por momentos fue
total
tras 20 años miles y miles de vidas
perdidas y un coste de más de 22
billones de dólares según cálculos de la
universidad de brown las dramáticas
imágenes de la retirada norteamericana
de ségou se volvieron a repetir aunque
en esta ocasión en un grado mucho
muchísimo mayor como pudo ocurrir como
pudieron los talibanes hacerse con el
poder tan rápido
las tropas americanas no pueden ni
deberían luchar en una guerra y morir en
una guerra por la que las propias
fuerzas afganas no están dispuestas a
luchar joe biden presidente de los eeuu
el presidente by den mintió y debe
avergonzarse hemos perdido 70.000
hombres en la guerra hemos llevado a
cabo el 95 por ciento de todas las
operaciones desde 2014 justo cuando
estábamos despejando para el soporte
aéreo los suministros y nuestras
comunicaciones fueron suspendidos sar
para comando afganos
nos ataron las manos a la espalda y
vendieron la patria maldito el rico y su
pandilla libraremos afganistán de estos
terroristas la historia juzgará a gun y
el amante de su banda general bismillah
mohammadi ministro de defensa de la
república islámica de afganistán
se suponía que las fuerzas de seguridad
afganas estaban preparadas tras casi 20
años de entrenamiento y preparación por
parte de las tropas internacionales tras
un gasto de eeuu de más de 80.000
millones de dólares y con supuestamente
350 mil unidades entre el ejército y la
policía militarizada la república de
afganistán tenía que resistir eso al
menos fue lo que nos vendieron
[Música]
23 de julio de 2018 estamos en el camino
correcto el ejército y la policía
afganos están demostrando su voluntad de
tener éxito john w nicholson juniors
general de cuatro estrellas y comandante
en jefe de las fuerzas estadounidenses
en afganistán entre 2016 y 2018
hemos provisto a nuestros socios afganos
de todas las herramientas permiten
enfatizar de todas las herramientas
entrenamientos y equipamiento de
cualquier ejército moderno hemos
provisto de armamento avanzado joe biden
pero qué ocurrió para que un ejército
que desde el año 2014 se ha
responsabilizado de más del 95 por
ciento de las operaciones militares de
repente se diluyera como un simple
azucarillo que pasó en afganistán para
que los talibanes hicieran de nuevo con
el poder sin apenas resistencia queridos
amigos y amigas por qué demonios cayó
afganistán en visual política hemos
preparado una trilogía de vídeos para
tratar de entender toda esta historia
pasado presente y futuro de la guerra
más larga de los eeuu de la última
derrota militar de la gran potencia
norteamericana vale nunca se pierde una
guerra de forma alegre eso es cierto
pero nadie imaginaba ver las estampas de
derrota o huida y descontrol que todos
hemos presenciado unas imágenes que
acompañarán para siempre como una pesada
carga de negligencia derrota y mal
acceder a la administración de joe baile
no había nada que yo ni nadie más viera
cada colapso de este gobierno en 11 días
general mark miller presidente del
estado mayor conjunto de los estados
unidos- amigos amigas en este primer
vídeo nos vamos a centrar en las cuatro
claves las cuatro hipótesis que explican
la arrolladora victoria talibán son
cuatro escenarios que se han producido y
que son complementarios entre sí lo que
no sabemos con certeza es el peso exacto
que ha tenido cada uno de ellos en la
debacle afgana pero sabemos que todos
ellos han contribuido decisivamente a lo
ocurrido
hemos sido traicionados nos dijeron que
un acuerdo de paz había sido alcanzado
que se estaba formando un gobierno de
transición que parásemos de luchar que
volviéramos a nuestras bases entonces
nos ordenaron que entregáramos todo a
los talibanes y veré más mientras pueda
recordar otro 11-s está en camino estoy
desolado zarpará comando afgano amigos
amigas así es como callo afganistán
atentos
la tradición de doha
[Música]
imaginad que sois el presidente de eeuu
y que tras 20 años de combate miles y
miles de baja y un gasto formidable
estáis empantanados en una guerra que
sabéis nunca podréis ganar o mejor dicho
que el coste y el sacrificio de intentar
ganarla es demasiado alto
recuerdo a afganistán como una pesadilla
beige polvorienta de un lugar lleno de
gente orgullosa y valiente que no nos
quería allí lo vi
imagina que en ese preciso instante os
presentan un plan señor presidente
tenemos la fórmula para escapar del
avispero tenemos un plan para evitar
nuevas bajas librarnos de la sangría
económica que supone la guerra impedir
que nuevos grupos terroristas campen a
sus anchas y de paso quizás lograr algún
rédito geoeconómico suena bien verdad
pues ahora imaginar que ese plan
consiste en pactar precisamente con los
talibanes e incluso facilitar su acceso
al poder que me habéis escuchado bien
queridos amigos amigas no sabemos si los
acontecimientos se desarrollaron
siguiendo este particular jan pero ellos
en la práctica es exactamente lo que
pasó
en 2018 el gobierno de trump le pidió a
pakistán que liberara al mulá abdul
ghaní baradar y el secretario de estado
de eeuu mike pompeo viajó y se reunió
con él para comenzar las negociaciones
de la web
no hablar en droga paladar es el actual
líder político de los talibanes el
resultado es que en febrero del 2020 se
firmó el acuerdo de doha un acuerdo al
que el gobierno afgano de ghaní se opuso
rotundamente aunque por supuesto no
sirvió de nada el acuerdo estableció un
calendario para la retirada de las
tropas internacionales la liberación de
miles y miles de presos talibanes y la
reducción de los ataques aéreos y
también de las operaciones militares
norteamericanas todo a cambio de que los
talibanes no atacaran a las tropas
internacionales
comprometieran a no dar cobijo a grupos
terroristas y negociarán con el gobierno
afgano una salida política al conflicto
with the list of
fighters santander al mantenerse stock
del elqui of si screen se instrumenten
with their médicos por crisis / cannes
sigue en crisis de tweets sin
información que no tiene siguiente
y eso es lo que se conoce porque buena
parte del acuerdo sigue y seguirá siendo
secreto es decir que los norteamericanos
negociaron la hoja de ruta del futuro de
afganistán no con el gobierno afgano que
ni siquiera estuvo en la mesa sino con
los propios talibán
el acuerdo de doha compró a los
talibanes un indulto de un año pudieron
reagruparse planificar fortalecer sus
líneas de suministro tener libertad de
movimiento sin temor a los bombardeos
estadounidenses andrew watkins miembro
del ibex institute of peace y en cierto
modo tiene sentido pensarlo bien
más allá de la cuestión moral que
plantea si impacta con los talibanes y
te aseguras de que no den cobijo a
grupos terroristas que puedan atacarte
miel sobre ojuelas no tendrás más bajas
podrás largar del país sin que al qaeda
o cualquier otro grupo que anpe sus
anchas podrás concentrar su atención y
tus recursos en tu auténtica prioridad
el pacífico y la contención de china y
si encima llegan al poder entonces bueno
entonces además incluso pueden abrirse
algunas oportunidades me explico
afganistán es un país muy rico en los
minerales más codiciados por la
industria tecnológica minerales como el
cobre el litio el cobalto el niobio las
tierras raras y también el oro y el
uranio de hecho según un informe del
propio pentágono del que se hizo eco el
york times' en 2010 afganistán tiene el
potencial de convertirse en la arabia
saudita del litio
además existen proyectos como el
gasoducto tapi un proyecto de gasoducto
que a través de mil 814 kilómetros
podría llevar gas natural desde
türkmenistán a pakistán india y china-
un proyecto que es propiedad de la
petrolera norteamericana chevron y que
podría aliviar la dependencia que china
tiene del gas natural ruso al tiempo que
reduciría la importancia estratégica de
irán pues bien en febrero de 2021 en una
visita según parece coordinada por los
propios eeuu los talibanes visitaron
türkmenistán y se comprometieron a
proteger este proyecto porque el
gasoducto amigos tiene que pasar por
afganistán
y el problema que había hasta ahora es
que para explotar los minerales o
construir redes energéticas se necesita
sobre todo estabilidad política mientras
estés en pie de guerra con los talibanes
no se puede hacer absolutamente nada
pero el acuerdo de doha suponía toda una
oportunidad para marcharse del país de
una vez por todas una operación al mejor
estilo cia
y eso eso es lo que para muchos
analistas se explica que eeuu dejará
prácticamente de atacar a los talibanes
a pesar de que estos recrudecieron sus
operaciones contra el ejército y las
instituciones afganas hasta el punto de
que naciones unidas calificó el 2020
como el año más violento en el país
desde que tiene registros claro que un
momento el acuerdo de doha puede
explicar si el escenario general perón
no basta para entender completamente por
qué demonios el ejército afgano se
dirigió tan rápido algo que incluso
pilló completamente desprevenido al
propio gobierno de los eeuu aunque lo
cierto es que la reducción casi total de
los ataques aéreos el retiro de los
contratistas de las fuerzas aéreas y la
consiguiente desmoralización de las
tropas afganas jugaron un papel clave
atentos
el saqueo por norma
[Música]
no es la primera vez que se produce una
desbandada en el ejército afgano madryn
usa en otoño del 2015 en la provincia de
kunduz una ofensiva de 500 talibanes
derrotó a 3000 soldados y policías
afganos y capturaron una capital
provincial por primera vez luego en la
provincia de helmand unos 1800 talibanes
vencieron a casi 4.500 soldados y
policías
corrieron tenían todo lo que necesitaban
efectivos armas municiones y se dieron
por vencidos o marian comandante del
ejército de afganistán
[Música]
ojo un apunte importante no nos
equivoquemos esto no quiere decir que el
efecto afgano no haya asumido esfuerzos
durante estos años los afganos han
llevado con mucho la peor parte tan solo
el ejército y la policía han acumulado
en torno a 70.000 bajas y desde luego
los comandos afganos las fuerzas
especiales se han ganado una reputación
en todo el mundo el caso la cuestión es
que tanto la desmotivación como la
escasez de materiales estaban a la orden
del día pero como puede un ejército en
el que se ha invertido tanto dinero más
de 80 mil millones de dólares en
prácticamente 15 años tener tantos y
tantos problemas pues una razón está en
el tipo de ejército que los eeuu
diseñaron un ejército montado a su
imagen y semejanza desplegado por todo
el país mediante una remota red de
puestos avanzados y bases una red
completamente dependiente de un complejo
sistema logístico y de apoyo compuesto
por aviones y helicópteros que los
afganos eran simplemente incapaces de
gestionar
cuando la provincia de kunduz cayó en
manos de los talibanes muchos soldados
murieron estábamos rodeados no había
apoyo aéreo en los últimos minutos
nuestro comandante nos dijo que no
podían hacer nada por nosotros que era
mejor huir todos abandonaron la guerra y
escaparon abdul qudus soldado afgano de
29 años
pero sobre todo tiene que ver con la que
quizás es la característica pagana más
destacada de las últimas décadas la
corrupción masiva y es que veréis a
pesar de las enormes cantidades de
dinero gastadas por los norteamericanos
los soldados afganos tenían sueldos
irrisorios se podían pasar meses sin
cobrar y hasta la munición escaseaba así
que claro cuando los talibanes aparecían
se marcaban todo un pablo escobar o
plata o plomo o se rendían y recibían
suministros e incluso cintas y algo de
dinero o les matarían a todos de hecho
se cree que los talibanes fueron
cerrando acuerdos de este tipo con
oficiales militares desde hace ya muchos
muchísimos meses
una región cayó como resultado de la
guerra sino como resultado de la guerra
psicológica
abbas tawakkol y comandante del
ducentésimo decimoséptimo cuerpo del
ejército afgano
todo el mundo simplemente entregó sus
armas y huyó no recibimos ninguna ayuda
del gobierno central por lo que el
distrito cayó sin ningún combate
rahimullah a un soldado afgano de 25
años
[Música]
la cuestión es que todo escaseaba porque
probablemente buena parte del dinero
gastado por los norteamericanos esté en
lugares como dubai o qatar por ejemplo
ahmed zia masud un exvicepresidente
afgano fue acusado de llevarse más de 50
millones de dólares ojo en efectivo a
dubai un lugar donde hoy vive en una
lujosa mansión y se pasea en rolls royce
otro ejemplo pues fijaos
los altos mandos del ejército del
gobierno mentían con las cifras de
soldados y se quedaban con el dinero de
muchas nóminas fantasma un buen día los
norteamericanos que pagaban más de 300
mil nóminas se dieron cuenta de que el
número real apenas superaba si acaso los
250 mil y de las nóminas que sí existían
habitualmente muchos altos mandos y
señores de la guerra se quedaban una
buena parte haciendo que los soldados
cobrarán cantidades aún más miserables
al final tuvieron que establecer un
sistema de pago electrónico y aún así
los problemas persistieron
pero no solo la cuestión de la cúpula
para nada la corrupción estaba
totalmente generalizada y es normal al
fin y al cabo sea un soldado que apenas
cobra unos 200 dólares mensuales cuando
los cobra le das un equipo valorado en
miles y miles de dólares el resultado no
puede extrañarnos y el mercado negro y
eso es exactamente lo que pasó cuando
por ejemplo el pentã gono trató de
equipar al ejército afgano con gafas de
visión nocturna desaparecían
constantemente y lo mismo ocurría con
componentes de los vehículos con las
armas la munición el combustible y con
muchos suministros total los
norteamericanos eran quienes pagaban las
facturas y además el control brillaba
por su ausencia además los soldados y
policías en muchos casos se dedicaban a
cobrar sobornos en los puestos de
control haciendo que buena parte de la
sociedad se fijara muy poco de ellos por
ser suaves de hecho la policía llegó a
convertirse en la institución más odiada
del país porque si los talibanes hacían
lo mismo pero una sola vez no como la
policía que exigía pagos constantemente
el principio talibán es una vez que
pagues el impuesto soborno te dan un
recibo que funciona en todo el país y no
se te pedirá que vuelvas a pagar el
impuesto un soborno los agentes de
policía por otro lado no emiten recibos
por los sobornos que extorsionan
ahmadzai y de yingjiang jefe adjunto de
la cámara de comercio de la provincia de
herat
así que si tienes un ejército en gran
medida mal entrenado mal equipado con
carencias de todo tipo y encima sin
motivación alguna el resultado pues es
exactamente el que hemos visto cuando
llegaban los talibanes y les amenazaban
muchas fuerzas y ya no se cambiaban de
bando y entregándole además a los
talibanes sus equipos militares marinos
a un fenómeno amigos que se recrudeció
cuando dejaron de tener el apoyo de los
estadounidenses sí y no luchaban por una
causa y es alrededor todo era corrupto
por qué demonios iban a jugarse el tipo
este factor amigos diezmo las fuerzas
afganas hasta niveles que en realidad
estaba muy pero que muy por debajo de
los 167 mil soldados que supuestamente
tenía el ejército en el momento en el
que los talibanes ocuparon todo el país
de hecho algunas fuentes apuntan a que a
la hora de la verdad apenas había 50.000
soldados mal equipados repartidos por
todo el país sin ninguna estrategia que
estuvieran dispuestos a luchar 50 mil
soldados el resultado todos lo conocemos
pero un momento porque no existen otras
dos hipótesis dos claves que no podemos
dejar pasar atentos
errores fatales pakistán
amigos amigas eeuu ha cometido muchos
muchísimos errores en afganistán el más
importante de todos quizás haya sido
haber sido incapaz de crear un ejército
y unas fuerzas de seguridad capaces de
vencer a los talibanes y aquí aquí
muchos analistas apuntan una cuestión
muy concreta el tiempo que se tardó en
montar un ejército afgano porque de
montar un ejército y una policía desde
cero no es nada sencillo pero hacerlo en
afganistán y encima sufriendo una
rotación enorme por las bajas sufridas
lo complica todo mucho muchísimo más
no tenemos que enseñar a los soldados
estadounidenses a obedecer la ley no
aceptar sobornos a respetar los derechos
humanos vienen al ejército habiendo ya
internalizado esas cosas tratamos de
crear militares a nuestra imagen y eso a
menudo no es congruente con las
circunstancias políticas y sociales en
las que operan esas fuerzas mike en
lagata es comandante de eeuu
el caso es que cuando estados unidos
invadió el país y derrotó a los
talibanes durante unos años hubo una
cierta calma pero obsesionados con irak
y con reducir el gasto comprometido el
presidente bush y el entonces secretario
de defensa donald rumsfeld cometieron lo
que a la postre se ha visto como dos
grandes errores primero rechazaron el
ofrecimiento de muchos líderes talibanes
de negociar una salida política y
segundo se empecinaron en afganistán
tuvieron las fuerzas de seguridad
ridículas de apenas cincuenta mil
hombres para controlar un país
gigantesco
además el pentágono quería reducir los
costes por lo que se empeñaron en
mantener bajos los salarios y cualquier
gasto derivado de la manutención de la
tropa para que os hagáis una idea cuando
se marchó rangel en 2006 y los talibanes
estaban intensificando sus ofensivas
apenas habían entrenado y equipado 26
mil soldados afganos la decisión resultó
ser por cierto carísima porque las
carencias del ejército afgano tuvieron
que ser cubiertas durante todos estos
años por tropas norteamericanas cuyo
coste de despliegue supera el millón de
dólares por unidad y año con todo lo
peor es que el ejército afgano nunca
llegó a consolidarse y pensaba que un
ejército moderno es mucho más que un
soldado por tanto un arma por ejemplo se
requieren mecánicos de todo tipo
profesionales de intendencia o sanitario
nada de eso habían afganistán por así
decirlo las decisiones de bussi rangel
supusieron desperdiciar los mejores años
al tiempo que alimentaron la corrupción
que antes hemos visto y por último
amigos por último está la hipótesis de
pakistán
muchos afganos y analistas consideran
que el ejército de pakistán ha entrenado
y equipado facilitado medios logísticos
e incluso cedido oficiales consultores y
tropas a los talibanes es decir que el
ejército afgano en realidad ha hecho
frente a una fuerza adiestrada en buena
medida por un ejército mucho más grande
y profesional pero porque pakistán
apoyaría a los talibanes pues
fundamentalmente para controlar
afganistán y evitar la influencia india
además está también el tema del
gasoducto tapi que podría suministrarle
gas al país
en fin estas son cuatro claves las
cuatro claves que tenemos que tener en
cuenta para poder entender la caída tan
rápida que se ha vivido en este país con
todas las imágenes que hemos visto
supone una mancha enorme en la gestión
de la administración vader el caos los
nervios la descordinación o un desastre
incluso los talibanes han tenidos
alcance y convertir a 2.500 soldados
norteamericanos en rehenes les hubiera
bastado con atacar la pista e impedir el
despegue y aterrizaje de aviones si no
lo han hecho es quizás porque anhelan
más el gobierno que la guerra ahora bien
qué podemos esperar de los talibanes a
qué futuro se enfrenta exactamente
afganistán qué ocurre con la resistencia
pues todo esto queridos amigos y amigas
lo veremos en dos próximos vídeos aquí
en visual político así que no olvidéis
suscribirse si aún no lo habéis hecho
una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]